ciao a tutte e tutti sono michele e
voglio iniziare questo incontro qui con
voi oggi come faccio di solito con i
gruppi a cui facilito propongo una
piccola attività per connettersi che si
chiama check in e non è quello che siete
abituati a fare in aeroporto quindi
carte e pennarello scrivete in grande se
siete online scrivetelo nei commenti
vi invito a chiudere gli occhi
e fare un respiro profondo
ora
ascolta il tuo corpo
e senti che emozione trovi adesso
racchiudi la in una parola e poi apri
gli occhi e scrivi la bella in grande
sul foglio
il check in è un'attività che vi invito
a proporre sia durante gli incontri di
lavoro glielo faccio sempre che in
famiglia
semplicemente serve una domanda in cui
ogni persona risponde uno alla volta e
gli altri ascoltano questo serve a
costruire
emozioni profonde e relazioni basate
sull'ascolto ora girate il foglio
diverse di me e vediamo se riesco a
vederlo
ok vedo emozione
curiosità sorpresa
io provo euforia e anche un po di paura
per essere qui sul palco con voi ecco
ora che l'ho fatto mi sento molto più
vicino a voi e la sensazione che ho è
che l'atmosfera un po cambiata su questo
in questo teatro
così posso raccontarvi la mia storia
inizia nel 2017 è in un periodo di crisi
dove metto in discussione tutta la mia
vita la start up che avevo co fondato a
san francisco era fallita da poco
in quei tempi lavorava un progetto a me
molto caro e un caro amico fabrizio mi
dice michele tu hai un sacco di passioni
dovresti trovare un modo per donarle di
più al mondo
questa frase rimane con me a lavorare
per mesi mesi e mesi con una domanda
ma come
poi un giorno guardando nell'app store
incontro un'applicazione musicali ora
conosciuta da tutti come tik tok la pro
per la prima volta e vedo una storia di
ragazzini che fanno balletti un po
strani tutti i matti
poi vedo che gli stessi ragazzini fanno
delle visualizzazioni incredibili
200.000 visualizzazioni in un giorno e
quindi dico wow che forza
poi noto che fuori dalle scuole o nei
giardini gli stessi ragazzini si muovono
e comunicano con le stesse movenze
quindi capisco che questa applicazione
ha una grandissima influenza su di loro
quindi anche io decido di mettermi in
gioco
e condividere quello che vedo in giro un
gattino rosso
bellissimo io ho solo 100 follower ma
questo gattino fa 45 mila
visualizzazioni nel giro veramente di 24
ore
e così capisco che su tik tok non è
importante il numero di follower che ti
seguono ma la qualità emotiva dei
contenuti che condividi
poi iniziano i trend e ce n'è uno in
particolare che mi colpisce quello dove
le persone in mostrano le proprie
fragilità
e quindi capisco che tik tok non è come
tutti i social dove devi per forza
metterti in mostra essere perfetto ma un
social dove si può essere più se stessi
così decide di condividere le mie storie
come mio nonno che oggi ha 93 anni e ha
scritto la sua autobiografia con l'aiuto
della famiglia e questo gli ha permesso
di non ripetere più domenica dopo
domenica alle storie che ci raccontava
della guerra ma di vivere nel presente e
costruire nuove relazioni donando il suo
libro e questo praticamente gli ha fatto
guadagnare dieci anni di vita
oppure di come io utilizzi una bottiglia
di vetro comprata per pochi euro al
supermercato come borraccia e questo mi
permetta di risparmiare fino a 133
bottiglie di plastica all'anno
o di quanto io adori l'alga spirulina
che ricca di clorofilla perché è un
potente alleato contro la denutrizione
nei paesi in via di sviluppo
e soprattutto è dieci volte più veloce
ad assorbire co2 dell'atmosfera e quindi
dieci volte più veloce di un albero e
quindi è un alleato fortissimo contro il
cambiamento climatico
sui tic toc mi accorgo che sto
condividendo le mie passioni e le mie
storie e mi accorgo che sto seguendo il
consiglio di fabrizio quello di donarmi
al mondo
e soprattutto che sto praticando uno dei
miei valori fondamentali la creatività e
per me i valori sono proprio ciò che ti
fa battere il cuore quello che ti dà
energia
un altro dei miei valori e la curiosità
e infatti mi domandavo ma chi ci sarà
dietro lo schermo a guardare i miei
video un po l'avevo capito dalle
statistiche però vedo che più del 50 per
cento a quei tempi aveva sotto i 29 anni
alcuni non sanno ancora scrivere bene
poi un giorno o l'illuminazione
pubblico un video di un minestrone
semplicissimo come lo fa mia mamma e mi
diverto a farlo me lo godo fino in fondo
fa 32.000 like nel giro di pochissimo
600 commenti guardo le analitiche
240 mila visualizzazioni sono come
quattro stadi di san siro pieni e poi ci
rifletto io ci ho messo quattro ore a
fare questo video di un minuto ed è
stato visto da mille 8 inter 1870 ore e
77 giorni
poi leggo i commenti
tu mi stai facendo venire un botto
voglia di minestrone o ma che
stregoneria e ma è questa
voglio le verdure e quindi rifletto ma
se io con un piccolo video la capacità
di modificare e influenzare le emozioni
che i ragazzi e le persone hanno sulle
verdure posso cambiare un po il mondo
e se per una sera questi ragazzi
chiedono alla propria famiglia di
mangiare un minestrone al posto della
classica bistecca di manzo
io ho contribuito a diminuire l'impatto
climatico di quella famiglia per quella
cena fino al 90 per cento
e quindi capisco che sto andando a
coltivare un altro dei miei valori
fondamentali e l'impatto il desiderio di
lasciare il mondo un po meglio di come
l'ho trovato
e di influenzare il mondo con i piccoli
gesti non collezioni gigantesche
così per più di un anno decido di avere
una sfida con me stesso pubblicare un
video al giorno e questo mi permette di
raccogliere un buon numero di follower e
i follower dalle nuove generazioni sono
qualcosa di veramente molto molto ambito
è il proprio valore quello che dà
importanza per me invece ho scoperto che
i follower sono più una grande rete di
supporto
con cui c'è uno scambio io dono
contenuti dono idee messaggi e loro mi
supportano ma a volte mi correggono è
una cosa bellissima
e quando ci si sente supportati si può
condividere la propria autenticità
come emozionarsi per un porro per un
casco fatto di anguria
e ovviamente mostrando la parte giocosa
la parte bambina
non tutti accettano
i commenti di odio gli insulti
sei un finocchio muori
sembri un serial killer
fanno male e mi toccano
ma malgrado questo cercato di praticare
un altro dei miei valori la gentilezza e
quindi mi sono detto ma dietro allo
schermo ci sarà una persona che ha avuto
una storia e che sarà stata portata a
scrivere quel commento per le sue
circostanze di vita che sono diverse
dalle mie
ma oltretutto
quel commento a un impatto su di me e
quello che faccio online in realtà si
ripercuote nella vita offline perché
siamo totalmente
interconnessi quello che facciamo ormai
è tutto on life
se sui social 6 in presenza siamo online
e sui social
tutto è amplificato è più veloce ma se
ci pensi tu su chi ha influenza
in primis
ha influenza su te stesso
le scelte che fai ogni giorno le
abitudine che hai l'attitudine che hai
verso il mondo verso gli altri tu sei il
maggior protagonista della tua vita e
sei la persona più importante che poi
influenzarla
poi ai influenza sugli altri i tuoi
figli tuoi parenti i colleghi le persone
che incontri quelli e quei comuni che i
suoi social ecco loro possono ispirarsi
date e dalle scelte che fai
e poi in realtà ha influenza su tutto il
mondo perché solo il fatto che siete qui
adesso state scambiando ossigeno e co2
con l'atmosfera e quindi state cambiando
il mondo
se decidi di fare un'azione gentile o di
fregartene cambierà il mondo comunque
perché ogni interazione interconnessa e
se decide di mangiare un minestrone
invece della classica bistecca di manzo
avrai influenzato positivamente il
futuro di chi produce vegetali al posto
di chi magari ha un allevamento
intensivo
quindi tu hai molto più potere di quanto
credi e tu sei influencer
quando io ho capito questo e ho capito
il potere delle mie azioni
un altro valore sia attivato la
responsabilità
e allora mi è sorta una domanda cosa ci
faccio con questa responsabilità come
posso usare la mia influenza per
contribuire a creare il mondo in cui
desidero vivere
e questa è la domanda che mi guida la
risposta che mi sono dato è stata prima
di tutto
informarmi continuare ad imparare
desiderare a prendere perché è una cosa
bellissima
poi conoscere i miei valori e averli
consapevoli e infine praticarli
quotidianamente
nelle sessioni di coaching che faccio
molte persone mi dicono sia influencer
che esecutive michele ma come faccio a
conoscere ne va e allora per voi oggi ho
preparato una piccola esperienza per
conoscere un vostro valore se vi fate
parla con me adesso vi invito a chiudere
gli occhi
fate un respiro profondo e
adesso pensa ad un episodio in cui ti
sei sentito soddisfatto per quello che
stavi facendo e in cui stava avendo un
impatto positivo sul mondo non serve che
sia qualcosa di grande la prima cosa
piccola che ti viene in mente
per me ad esempio è stato fare quel
video del minestrone
quando hai quell'episodio adesso pensa a
quale valore ai espresso in questa
storia era chiudilo in una parola anche
questa non deve essere perfetta
l'importante che abbia quell'energia
quel battito che ti fa andare avanti
e ora che hai trovato quella parola
domandati che azione posso fare per
coltivare questo valore almeno un minuto
al giorno
per me ad esempio è stato condividere un
video per più di un anno l'azione
piccola continua a tenere gli occhi
chiusi
la sfida è l'invito che ti faccio è la
prossima volta che comunichi a qualcuno
nella pausa caffè o se sei online scrive
lo nei commenti mi farà un sacco piacere
leggerlo
condividi una tua storia di uno di
questi valori qualcosa che per te è
importante che sai che può influenzare
le altre persone perchè facendo questo
vai a rafforzare il tuo clima interiore
e a influenzare e cambiare il clima
sociale ed esteriore
però poi aprire gli occhi
quello che voglio lasciarti con questo
talk che spero che abbia un po cambiato
anzi ne siamo sicuri abbiamo scambiato
co2 e ossigeno è che la rivoluzione dei
social dell'on life è che hai molto più
potere di quanto immagini e che se anche
non lo vuoi sei un attivista e stai
cambiando il mondo adesso se pratichi
tuoi valori puoi contribuire
ogni giorno a crescere e vivere nel
mondo in cui desideri vivere veramente
bene
ogni piccolo gesto fa assolutamente la
differenza e ricorda tu sei influencer
grazie
[Applauso]